[Music]
hello there Marge is rummed full of
amazing games begging for your time and
money and I'm here to help you decide
which is for you from the AAA to the
free to play and everything in between
today's video is sponsored by Focus
entertainment as atomic heart is now
fully released we'll be looking at that
a little later in the video so let's do
this
the jaw-dropping game of the month is
Resident Evil 4 remake you know the deal
by now Capcom are systematically
remaking their iconic survival horror
games to a whole new standard after re2
in 2019 and re3 a year later this time
Leon returned to save the daughter of
the president of the United States who
is currently captured in rural Spain as
a mind-altering parasite is taking over
the locals gameplay is a blend of third
person shooting and puzzle elements
scattered in we are told the Remake will
go beyond the boundaries of the original
with new side quests and more fleshed
out story missions and there's loads of
extras the return of the mercenaries
mode is here to see how many bad guys
you can take out before the helicopter
leaves and those on psvr 2 one day a
free update will be coming so you can
play the entire game in virtual reality
and if you're unsure any day now a timed
free demo will be dropping for anyone
who wants to try before they buy
Resident Evil 4 remake releases on March
24th on Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
whoa long Fallen dynasties next on our
list an action RPG that comes from the
developers of Neo and dark souls and
although the template is definitely
based on the sacred soulsbon genre it is
implemented in a more gamer friendly way
morikin to Eldon ring we create a
nameless soldier who must fight demonic
beings found in the world setting China
during the Three Kingdoms period which
was IRL the most bloodiest in China's
history layer on top of that a few
fantasy elements and you have well long
multiple fighting styles to master gear
and armor upgrades magical spells and
divine beasts we can summon like Pokemon
and this is another game with a playable
demo which is out right now the full
game releases on March 3rd on
Playstation Xbox and PC
next atomic heart I've teamed up with
Focus entertainment to tell you about my
time with the game a science fiction
first person shooter that sees the
perfect world we live in ripped apart by
technology that once served us luckily
we have an experimental Power Glove
which can harness superpowers and in the
other hand we have a range of firearms
to utilize and when those bullets are
spent melee becomes the focus the range
of weapons is definitely important as
each of the enemy Ai and mutants have
different traits and fighting styles
like the constantly pursuing mustache
Bots that stride forward like the T-1000
in Terminator do all the balletic style
of the twins wow anyway enemy designs
are equally amazing and unnerving from
my own time with the game the standout
moments for me came from the puzzles
which are kind of like portals test
Chambers constantly building on
previously learned skills to progress
forward IGN tell us atomic heart is an 8
out of 10 so it's damn good if atomic
heart sounds like your kind of game
there's a link you should click in the
description
[Music]
a game which looks very interesting is
Cheer and it's coming to Playstation
Plus on release day later this month
Chia calls itself an action adventure as
we play as an Explorer in a sprawling
tropical open world Chia has a funky
Soul jumping mechanic allowing the
player to take over animals we see and
hundreds of inanimate objects too I've
been told it's like playing as Moana but
with Maui's shape-shifting ability the
game is filled with story missions from
NPCs to look out for and wow there is a
playable ukulele on top of that there
are hundreds of unlockable Cosmetics but
sadly on release at least Chia is a
single player game and I feel like
that's a missed opportunity but we'll
have to wait and see Gia hits PS plus
extra on March 21st and it's also on PC
too
okay let's do some more free stuff that
I found this month remember in January I
told you about cart Rider drift well I
was a little early on that as the
preseason was only for PC and mobile but
now it's time for PlayStation and Xbox
to jump on board it may look like a
basic Mario Kart clone but it turns out
this series is bigger than Mario Kart in
other regions of the world and now they
are trying once again to widen their
reach after it's called cat Rider drift
is just like Mario Kart pick up some
power-ups used to hold the lead long
enough to take the checkered flag but
there's also an Esports level of racing
hidden in here where drifting rewards
energy to the Boost mechanic which can
be utilized whenever the player sees fit
if you do play it I beg you to complete
your licenses they are the way to unlock
more content quickly cat Rider drift
hits PlayStation and Xbox on March 8th
a less impressive free-to-play game that
you can download right now is pinball FX
definitely a pretty Niche title for
lovers of pinball tables there are some
damn impressive licenses in game from
Indiana Jones to Star Wars the gameplay
is exactly what you expect our trigger
buttons on the controller are the
flippers on the table in game unlocking
tables is the way they plan to get your
money but I've played for a few weeks
now and tables do regularly pop up on
the store for a few days if you need
more content pinball FX is free to
download right now if that's your jam
hey want to get an early start on a
potentially huge free-to-play game which
releases later in the year check out
wayfinder a free to play online RPG in
which we play as the title role
wayfinders explorers and Protectors of
the land who must take out any enemies
that stand in their way of course I'll
tell you more about the game when I've
played it but if you want to play the
game earlier than most people you can
sign up for the beta from February 28th
on PlayStation 4 5 and BC the plan for
the game is an early access release in
May and then a full release later in the
foreign
take a look at this 20 game it's flying
under the radar right now deceive Inc a
multiplayer covert Espionage game where
the goal is to steal a briefcase and
Escape without being found by other
players interesting right as we walk
around we appear to be an NPC to the
other players and must act that way
performing covert tasks but should
things go completely wrong it's possible
to turn this into a shooter and take out
all your enemies and forcibly grab that
briefcase deceiving looks like he's
doing something different and that needs
to be cherished look out for it on March
21st on Playstation Xbox and P to the
Sea back to full price games now WWE is
back 2K 23 continues the style scene in
previous years with an arcade cross
simulation approach this time war games
are making their debut in which two
freaking wrestling rings sit side by
side in a cage other confirmed game mode
see my factions my GM showcase mode my
Rise And The Creation Suite all return
and the Showcase this time round is
based on John Cena's career and we
replay his matches to live through his
high points I didn't see that coming WWE
2k23 release day is March 17th on
Playstation Xbox and PC
[Music]
there are so many more games dropping in
March so let's do a quick fire round PC
players you may have been enjoying the
Last of Us TV show and now you should
know it's finally time for you guys to
play the Remake remaster I'm still not
sure of the 2013 Last of Us game now
named Last of Us Part One complete with
the sublime Left Behind DLC hitting
Steam on March 28th psbr players you
guys have a horror roller coaster coming
your way on March 16th in the shape of
the dark pictures Switchback VR annual
sports games start to drop again fooling
us into buying games with minimal
updates MLB the Show on March 23rd and
PGA Tour golf on March 24th if you're
still watching the video at this point
here's a dad joke for your troubles I
used to be addicted to soap but now I'm
clean I'm Adam you're awesome sorry
about that see ya
[Music]